let's get happy this is the Mile Line we  share the stories that we think are  going to be smiling about all day long  so let me lay it on you baby Asher's  parents Shawna and Alex Farrington say  they were shocked when it sounded like  he said I love you at just four months  old now here's what is unusual about  that babies usually start talking around  their first birthday take a listen  hey Asher I love you  I love you yeah  I mean genius I'm gonna say because I'm  gonna be a dad soon that if I heard that  it was my kid I'd probably be like  they're talking they're talking of  course but I did say that well well he  said it but I mean you know saying it  means intending to say oh come on  all right I'm gonna speak out of two  sides of my mouth here well never mind I  got four seconds he said it he's a  genius